frédéric viale bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
8000 spectateurs lors de la finale de la
league cup dans trois semaines c'est en
tout cas l'objectif de boris johnson
grâce au pass aux passeports sanitaires
dont il présentera les détails cet après
midi à votre avis ce projet at il des
chances d'être adoptée par le parlement
britannique
oui bien entendu il le sera enfin je ne
veux pas céphalées toutes les conditions
sont réunies pour qu'il pour qu'il le
soit et d'ailleurs il faut voir aussi
que ce type de projet on va la voir chez
nous également très très rapidement là
si vous voulez le royaume uni va
franchir une première étape c'est
vraiment le pied dans la porte
ça va être le premier à mettre en place
un passeport sanitaires et les autres
pays occidentaux en suivre très
nécessairement les états unis vont
suivre pourquoi tout simplement pour
fluidifier comme on dit les rencontres
sportives etc
cet add on va avoir cette situation d'un
contrôle massif de la population par les
qr codes au nom de l'urgence sanitaire
alors vous l'avez dit plusieurs pays
sont actuellement en train de travailler
sur l'idée d'un pass and it erp à
l'échelle de l'union européenne est ce
que vous vous pensez que les vingt-sept
justement peuvent s'entendre sur un
dispositif commun ça va arriver
logiquement très très très très vite
puisque toutes les conditions politiques
sont réunies pour ça l'union européenne
elle-même ne décidera rien puisque c'est
pas de ses compétences ce sont
uniquement des compétences des états est
nécessairement ils vont se mettre
ils vont se mettre d'accord très vite et
ils vont se mettre d'accord en
s'alignant sur ce qui se fait déjà et ce
qui se fait déjà ses lancers par la
grande bretagne où ça va se faire très
vite et donc on va avoir un passeport
sanitaire mis en place
ce passeport sanitaire qui est avec la
technique de qr code va être très
facilement et tendent à bhl à toutes les
activités
social et économique et je parie enfin
c'est pas un pari je vous le dis d'ici
trois ans nous serons dans la même
situation que la chine syrien se passe
c'est à dire que nous aurons un contrôle
par le qr code non pas seulement pour
entrer sur le territoire mais aussi pour
rentrer dans un magasin pour entrer dans
un théâtre pour rentrer dans un cinéma
et cetera et c'est donc là véritablement
7 c'est très important vous en parliez
merci d'en parler cette décision
inaugurale de la grande bretagne est le
premier pas vers un contrôle massif au
nombre de deux des populations au nom de
l'urgence sanitaire encore une fois on
sait également que la grande-bretagne
entame une étape majeure du nez
confinant la semaine prochaine avec la
réouverture des commerces et essentielle
mais aussi les terrasses des restaurants
l'a finalement c'est grâce au succès de
la campagne de vaccination que le pays
peut avancer plus vite que ses voisins
qu'est-ce que cela
voilà nous dit par rapport à l'europe
qui finalement a raté quand même pas mal
de choses depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire
bah comme vous venez de le dire l'europe
rate beaucoup de choses et il est très
clair qu'un pays qui prend lui est lui
même ses décisions et qui prend des
décisions souveraines dont ce domaine là
en tous les cas dans ce domaine là mais
ça pourrait être également dans les
autres arrivent à des résultats
nous avons pris d'un point de vue
idéologique on a un président la
république a décidé d'attendre
d'attendre attendre que l'union
européenne fasse le travail qu'elle ne
fait pas moralité on est extrêmement
retard et comme par ailleurs on est
totalement dépendant puisque aujourd'hui
la france est un pays parfaitement des
classes et qui n'a pas été capable de
mettre en place
elle mène son propre vaccin eh bien on
se trouve dans une situation où tout à
l'heure j'entendais un sujet vous le
gouvernement affirmait que ça les
vaccinations auront lieu en été s'ils
saluent en été on aura beaucoup de
chance la souveraineté de l'union
européenne est donc remise en question
elle n'existe pas elle n'existe pas il
n'y a que des souveraineté des états et
en tout l'état l'union européenne a bien
montré que quand il s'agit de coordonner
les choses le
lentement elle le fait mal et le
résultat c'est qu'on est extrêmement
retard or quand on est en retard dans ce
genre de choses eh bien ça veut dire que
les variants se développe ça veut dire
que la vague augmente et que donc on
n'arrive pas au bout du problème comment
les britanniques
voilà accueille-t-il justement ces
étapes de déconfinement on sait un boris
johnson a voulu se montrer très prudent
il a pris son temps comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on réagit du côté de
londres
ben j'imagine en tout cas c'est très
logique les populations sont toujours
contents de pouvoir refaire un certain
de choses qu'elle ne pouvait pas faire
jusque là
et c'est parfaitement légitime qu'elle
en soit qu'elles en soient heureuses
nous en serions très contents aussi si
nous pouvions le faire
or du fait et l'impéritie de l'union
européenne et de l'impéritie de notre
gouvernement
on reste coincé et malheureusement on va
rester coincé un long moment
et j'ajoute à cela du fait maintenant de
l'urgence sanitaire du fait qu'on n'en
sort pas que ça va être très long et
c'est derrière on va avoir des mesures
parfaitement liberticides comme celle de
la mise en place d'un passeport
sanitaire dans un premier temps d'un qr
codes généralisée dans un deuxième temps
qui fait que encore une fois je le
répète nous aurons la même situation de
contrôle des populations qui existent en
chine d'ici au maximum trois ans merci
beaucoup en tout cas frédéric viale
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste des
questions européennes et auteur du livre
manifeste contre les accords
transatlantique aux éditions eric
boullier